you
so there's the link if you want to hop
in this is the Eastern Bull Arena 55
minutes remaining
in our tournament
so let's play some 1-minute chess
seller seller lore
build a Center
point pieces at their king defend d5
take me let's get to
open file so I'll punch at the night
he's not going anywhere I'm up a piece
let's see if I can convert this being up
a piece get upon another pond and a fork
okay they're giving me the clean let's
enter are they stopping mate pre move it
polite resign back to tournament land
okay
seventy-five players seventy-six players
are in here
late joining by five minutes is nothing
tournament for one minute
lot of those hyper bullet tournaments
the one-hour hyper bullets and a lot of
games in with that
alright let's just let's just keep this
tension continue to keep the tension I
have to be careful of this advance let's
kick this night away let's try to break
this structure down some how long can I
hold off on this tension
let's go here this this is a sensitive
point you take there I take here I don't
know if this is really favoring me it's
not favoring me I'm just losing stuff
actually pawn takes pawn will be a
blunder I could take here I'm on c5
twice I am definitely worse here may be
threatening a4 they're going to give up
the dark square Bishop no where's that
not gonna go not even up timewise
alright I guess we're going to break it
up now I have some some rooks that can
maybe do something dangerous pigs
I would love some pigs
get some pigs I'm getting some bonds not
getting the pigs I'm getting pawns
sneaky check throw in their time burn
their lands
I'll take their pigs trade can
that pollen F recaptures I don't want to
do that
you
yo the down and time I got to play a
different system
all right how about we see in Kerala
matter what
queenside fianchetto threatened to win
that e4 pawn pawn grabber
one grabber
there we go strike at the center improve
the night get to the DNC files right now
there you go
improve they could have captured their
ruin my structure let's just swing over
here okay
you
was I going to say I get to uh ooh I get
to take a free rook pigs there you go
that's going to be the theme just try to
try to acquire pigs
every game you play
we'll take care we don't wanna make any
checks
I could just let's just do it I'll give
them up kind of boatload of pawns a
boatload
we keep on
don't stalemate no stalemate no
stalemate no stalemate no stalemate all
right we got it
laughs my train of thought with that one
yeah
49 minutes left in this tournament
player for fin 83 best buy test we're
going hippo not the greatest move order
for it what's rook to b8 about okay some
clarification in the center push the F
on down the blacks throw the freeing up
this guy maybe I should have inserted b4
first
let's continue put the nine on f4 nine
on f3
this guy is biting on a rock so go here
there might be some peace act right
there what's that move about
jump in here
Bishop to f4 ooh queen trapper Oni love
it they knew it was coming too that's
why they didn't take any five they
sensed it
it's just a defense e2 so my queen could
go elsewhere
trade the rook alright a bishop move I
got some now
lined up
together
the rook here's the mate
where is the mate
they resigned back to tournament
okay 99 players are in there
Alejandro BR already
and
they're breaking the pin alright let's
hunt that light-square bishop down can I
kill their structure no their Queens
there to defend let's still jump in here
and what about this
they sneak over where there's some
weaknesses here
I may just take that fun may
stop but look there's
bit weakening
probably good idea to play here yeah
it's kind of scary okay let's let's open
it up
clean exchange I'm cool it ooh now their
structure is really hard
put the night on a good square are they
going to be in an infinite PIN
tricky night
I think I want to keep a look around
just one rook
two versus one I think everything is a
cool over here and I should be able to
continue marching with these guys or
pickup upon
armed and they resigned
a thief
going to take h2
but it should still probably still would
have been winning there
all right
ooh Tino
five each floor all right uh why not
it's bullet you could do whatever you
want
you can throw your H pawn down like that
no rule against that I want to
I love with my night
clean exchange I'm okay with that
and there's straighten out their pawns
um
yeah
down I'm down upon
what I think he just says I don't I
don't really like that I'm down upon I
wish I wasn't down upon
that nights really going to hurt me
really going to hurt me I got to work
some magic with these nights
they are tricky
get tricked
careful now ooh looks like I'm getting
tricked
looks like I am the one getting tricked
I got
break something open here my night is
going to be running really short on
squares soon I don't know how to resort
to time burner stuff
careful now that's a clever move
let's take upon
whoa
gotta go faster
Oh
and of anytime
you time player
dodged the bullet
serious bullet
in that bullet game now is his first
last good player
run I got 20 in first 24 21 20
try an old Indian
let's shoot for b5 let's scare him away
can I take this pawn without getting
hurt I'm a chicken let's just close it
up
play for f5 next right now
let's take
Oh
okay gotta get rid of one of these
bishops they're too strong
okay now I have an enormous knight on e5
and h3 struck at one upon
fleet development Queen g5 hang on
clean was throwing a punch at my bishop
five square got it double on the F file
am I missing night announcer you could
take on g3 King is on a light square
let's go here fight for that f3 square
they're ignoring it
back up defend my base point
I guess here just want to double up
continue to double are they in trouble
they could take care
here again
okay he's got to go down
tonight one a piece
on them
no time back to term
alright I'm in first twenty four with
fire forty minutes to go
1:18 in this one
all righty
we get next
Kentucky Fried liver
be demon
I'm getting berserk
I get to check
and
[Music]
this night away
that was silly
I forgot that the night
just go and take up on
not cool but they don't have much time
and that's a serious problem
and again a rook let's continue
checks first and they just resigned I
wasn't going to end well I had at
minimum the Rickon
h1
probably more maybe maybe even mate
okay see for what kind of sin are they
going to have now
they've given me a Center they've given
me a fork they which one do I want I'll
take the bishop and try to show that
this guy is a monster a monster
okay some success
[Music]
whoops
change of plans
like when really didn't have a great
square to go to
I guess here don't like I'm planning
this night on f4 is getting too too
complicated let's throw the night in
here alright now we're going to look at
these squares night right here is some a
really good move
winning stuff we just want to get rid of
the night centralized
trade be a trading machine put stuff on
dark I could have captured the bishop
was free there he returned
on the victory lane
they resigned back to term in 32 26 22
1:25 in here
and don't ask me why
don't ask me why did that
out that this player plays like this is
launching of
a bunch of ponds
you know
let's just let's just do what
[Music]
let's try to open it up
working very well they could push
around
they're going to keep it closed
let's sack
[Music]
you
yeah
say I got a castle sometime
their Bishop is excellent
I am incensed
is trouble aren't they in trouble they
are made it out of nowhere
I forgot about that player it's the same
kind of uh
thing that they do
seeing kind of the clean bishop and then
play
the other flank with these uh rip on to
the third rank and Knight pawn to the
fourth rank thing
let's try a Kings Indian
I really got lucky in that one
okay now watch the e4 square roots will
secure my night okay so
giving me that square let's hop to it
let's get serious maybe we revisit this
square can the queen be chased around I
want this night to move can I get that
guy to move come on move night any way I
can force that I don't see a way I could
force that had some dark
our weaknesses Queen's a goner she's a
goner just like that
check
got some good pieces I don't have much
time though there's a rook
you're dropping
oh boy
covering a lot of ground those guys okay
l40 they resigned
okay this guy strobe III
sky I'm not hang up on the deep on until
okay let's looks let's come in with this
b5 changing the structure
let's try to break it up
okay I gotta get rid of their dark
square bishop
and then I want to put
this
let's change the structure
they can't take I didn't think they
could take
this guy
got to hunt him down
I must drive my queen
priority
rook takes pawn I had a fork and even
here I have this I'm cool with this
because I have a runner
so here here here chop and then push
away
you know they resigned is going to be
pretty clear-cut there
trade down some
okay
six c5 okay they're doing a lot of non
developing moves so
let's try to put my pieces to work a
little bit weakening for sure to do this
especially with the bishop there but
let's go here I'm threatening Knight b5
now they're in some serious trouble now
yeah this is this is a game over
because he becomes an absolute animal
here
here
hold that fork for a move wait for one
of the rooks to move first
and then we take have them waste time
okay they challenge me let's take the
guy in the corner force there rip to the
corner
and then just break this down get up
there King let's take this pawn
incoming
let's just do this I could have captured
here as well
I want to get at this
and this is
all falling
they resigned back to terminal
8:28 27:31 and change Kentucky fried
liver again
getting berserk
fishing pole action I think
um let's give them c4
away trying to fishing-pole me
I feel it
I feel
you know they're definitely trying to
fishing plumbing
it is scary
it is scary
that cutting fishing pole yet they're
trying to be sneaky
he's there in time
no you will not get to f2
that night
you
and they resigned at the rook
they only we're working with that night
next to my king
coordinate the clean with that night
they didn't have anything
all right we're going to see you cut Oh
hmm giving me a pond
let's just move out the way play d4
ship d3m
clear pond
Knight to d5 at some point just want
this in suck the bishop back on Knight
to b4
lies sneaking a flight square they're
lacking a plan oh I forgot that they
could do that
nice I do have this move though
this
all right let's go here on a battery I'm
going to take this night and then the
force off the light squared Bishop snek
and let's just
operate on light squares
have some of my I want the rooks top
rate on light squares
pawns control some dark
she doesn't go into pacman mode someday
in
challenge him
where's the bishop going to go
let's go here trying to get to this
square
not letting me
I control these two open files
I don't like the technique I'm using
helpful
[Music]
very poor conversion right here
yeah I got to try something else
yeah that's maybe a start
that's helpful
for sure
just gave up that pun
you
who they got mated I thought somehow my
flag fell there
the case
all righty 56 30 30 30 a lot of 30s whoa
a lot of 30s they're all with fire it's
funny
maybe we could go benoni land
nope no c4 on board
strike with c5
keep on playing to fourth-ranked pawns
we'll go with
centralized
let's open up his eyes
sneaking a flight square I don't know if
it's timed well okay I'm fine with that
exchange let's go here I want to get on
this diagonal
stick with the night
could always get out of this with a
queen b7 move
now
and let's go here may be threatening
this and also a mate made idea Knight h3
not quite mate now
they opened themselves up for the h2
square but now I have G for
I want some pieces exchanged
don't know how I pulled this off
let's go here
could be in some trouble night here
might be good
about that
all right the rooks are exchanged
very close on the clock
applicated yeah shouldn't have allowed
that
Ponda fix them on light squares
he's going to be a target soon
came down
tough to make progress here
King has to go back now
then
anytime
it was winning in the end only after the
bishops were exchanged with the bishops
on I believe it's a draw
okay
camed Sammy zero
you played earlier
okay
clean side
let's see how they react to
d5
support my
can't feel too comfortable they're going
to move forward
Wow
orthocenter like this
by night they're not doing that c6
protected let's try to undermine I want
to get at their king I didn't want to
have to drop this guy
okay
okay he can't he can't be captured
because of Bishop c4
Brook here I give a check on the C file
so I'm up a rook
take him oh my god I almost thought I
could not stop that pond
almost
I am giving the
or the material back
I would have ended up in a pin now I
want to take I will take next
let's back up
they're being sneaky there oh and now
they're in a pin
no time and they resigned back to
tournament got 64 36 35 32
151 in this
the Panda is there
okay
chest wins
I guess g6 start down the dark square
bishop alright he's not going anywhere
let's try 4 E 5
b5 is in and push him away try to
they have that pond they were really
quick to spot that
and this pond I'm giving away material
but they're not not taking every piece
of material giving them
he's really good there bishop
keep open this option for a check like I
should have some
attack let's just continue chucking
these pawns
ready to enter on f3
and this should be made
you
there they would go here I'll have a rep
check can I get away with this
mate into threat yes when I get it
yes I am going to get it
I did that earlier with the king here
there's clean c32 force the Queen
exchange they had a stop queen here it
into h2
take position I've found for this type
of idea with the Queen like playing a
move like going to c7 and before you
know you can't even stop Queen h2 next
it's one of those silent but deadly
moves then I capture a check but
throwing a really strong punch
sixty-eight 40v panda
all righty Panda
Oh the benoni we're not going to go for
the snake
the regular old boning
here
yeah I think if any for actually that's
why they're pausing it's only because
they pause that I paused there let's
take
and
and this isn't the way you get the peach
back by the way I
yeah this was not right abort abort ah
man
okay I got to hope that my night end up
ends up on a five that's not happening
either now I'm going to struggle I am in
big big trouble here
yeah that's not the way you get the
piece back I shouldn't do that
just going to get that pond
you take I got a hope
tricky night is extra tricky extra
tricky it's not happening
you're trying to get them off stop it
ricky-rock
mates
okay
is getting at least a little bit
complicated
it's getting a little bit complicated
you
man I had to be sneaky with the clock
only on time
I shouldn't have captured on e4 the
reason why I played Richard I was
if I played the intended f5 they would
have captured on d6
goofed in that sequence
let's play with d6 and we're going to
have the knight be the one that bounces
on the d6 square
[Music]
let's try to tie something in with that
night something is going to happen on f7
something really good really good really
really good the exchange and the Queen
back to tournament
i'm a-- i'm a hamster
thank you too I'm a hamster for the sub
alright
let's try the French we've played many
games where we go into an exchange Caro
not happening here
that LightSquared bishop very strong
to trap me
let's go here 9f5 there okay let's open
it up maybe we get up there King
can I dive in
let's try this
the smooth working
now they have a queen move
let's try this
I move my pond they're going to get on
this diagonal just like I did in the
last game
you
it's very weakening what I'm doing
very very weakening and I just spent
so much time
Tyrael now that's what I really need
the winner of some material
you
I'll push
get this
but my knight on d5
clean exchange
I got the rook
and I run like the wind blows
you
holy cow point six eight seconds left
for me barely barely barely I'll take it
let's call
man
that was too close
ah
a too close
yeah just a little too
there can I go inside
alright let's open it up
even if a cost upon
improve the night
push break it open break it open improve
this night
and
[Music]
next
defend the night hit here
Finch
I'm getting Adam
double up
enter take get to the seventh
let's take continue to enter slow down
for a second
let's break like that
who
let's defend the night hub I push here
we finally enter
and there we go that's the way
let's just take the piece
[Music]
That's not me
we run it like this
that's me that's a pretty cool name 8450
644
okay
drugs is up
quick kill
it's worth a shot
maybe sneak in a quick winner
um
[Music]
I want to be able to neutralize this
diagonal
really quick
let's just go here for starters
the rook
for a queen exchange defend my night
and the queen is taking away probably
the best square from their night
okay over here we both need a flight
square and a little bit more active with
my queen
return to the home square challenge and
I get to recapture the check this is
important so I want to make sure I could
take control over this otherwise rip to
d1
scoop this guy up and recapture and
defend f7 I still need a flight square
h6 is it
let's stick around
go here get out of any diagonal checks
um actually what
the Queen's off at this point
a seventh inch making over
jumped over here but I could create a
passed pawn stuff to get them going
oh they thought I was going to go here
ten seconds is plenty let's do it like
this
there we go back to tournament 88 6046
tend to go
t7 in there
okay Kentucky Fried liver again is
berserk evening
when to throw in against Kentucky Fried
liver
when they're in speedy Gonzalez mode
why not
not now
you
already crashing through
and they are in a giant pickle now
let's just create a passed pawn I was
going to keep my queen and rook sitting
there
in my queen and rook would tie up their
rook Knight and King to pieces
restricting three
alright another old Indian
the structure maybe not
all right let's try it we should be for
I have c5
Kyle
I want to get my pawn to a4
this is now they might have trouble
contesting
only open file because when my night
moves
I've pressure on this point now this is
a hole
is excellent now
my knight is in a really good spot
Square stop night here
take
um
[Music]
I could do this
let's take with the pond
let's try to try to push him away
I didn't have to go about it in this
this manner
so they could have done that a little
bit sooner
and the one I'm taking right here
yeah
take that night out I think I might have
to know
I should be able to play much faster now
at this night around
one
[Music]
our get out
you
why did I try to move the night
it's too hard to move the night
I should have been able to pre move that
one out much better mmm
ah man
I hate losing those games
I hate losing those gay
so much
okay
why are they going clean side
you
okay
just push my ape on up
mm man
came back
came back
let's break it open over here
for trouble
my queen on a7
to have to deal with this trap
tank
I should have just pre moved with my
king it's so much easier you only have
to take one little step
is going to light squares
jabo jangles thank you for the resub
nine months in a row man appreciate the
support
chest wins again
okay yeah this was the one the game
where I had that made on h2
my night is actually going to return
home because he loves loves the b4
square
maybe my other night loves it too
maybe he else do this very
very odd approach but
why not
okay maybe we play on the a file
threaten to wind up on
hug upon hunting
got b3
he might have been trapped if I
do something like this maybe they take
so here
want to break with this really soon
take with the rook
not quite working I don't think
funny situation at those rooks
I want to maintain this guy here two
versus zero now bring the King over
maybe I could try to convert this in a
smooth way smooth
it's smooth
your book it's all you have to do just
don't drop your book you're golden
just don't drop your rock
the leader
love that
don't like my approach okay
Stephen
keep pushing
I don't how much time
just take him
you
let's see if I get pre-move
supreme of test 1.8 seconds men
could put a hundred up there one one
went away I got some fire
- 30 remain
all right what do we throw a caged g3
that about
going h-bond crazy
all right
we have to shoot for f4 it's our way to
break open
position so pressure
upon and now this is collapsing they're
giving me a night
turn the way
let's just go here
oh they're not
giving me stuff now
they saw go
or something
now I'm
try for this kind of stuff
and start I'll insert
b4 I'm kind of stopping that
to improve the nights they
six
anything
for works
and
rade
this
is the mate
spy
really close by
is going to hurt
next nope not quite
check mate next that's going to do it
maybe one more
35 seconds probably not think if it hits
27 28 closed yeah
okay that's going to do it one speed
bump mmm I still felt like I should have
had that one but there are plenty of
games in there where I should have lost
okay
III in all
let's see other pages
mm chest ninja who is that we've never
played
we got confetti
three 18 pages and all
good turnout for an Eastern bold arena
there
I see interesting played a handful okay
to the 172 of you good games all